hi  who is that  who is that shy  hi  this is your brother  oh  be careful shy be careful be nice  be careful charlie oh  be careful  you give it kiss right here give it a  kiss  you can give a kiss give your brother a  kiss  oh  okay  good job  [Music]  my  ovaries melted like my heart just  completely sobbed into a million  oh i can  give him a kiss jay give your brother a  kiss  oh  good job  okay  this whole time i was waiting for shai  to meet him to see what what it's going  to be like and he was so tired too i was  trying to keep shy away because he was  late he was past his bedtime so he was  like  look at me i'm crying thinking about it  it was so sweet see okay you want more  then i  i didn't say that  imagine both of them hugging a third one  suffocate that one  [Music]  you